- I'm Famo Musa, I'm a refugee,
and also I'm a mother of two.
I'm a student and I would
say I'm a photographer.
I don't know, I'm just a human being.
I was born in Somalia
but I grew up in Kenya.
I came here back in 2004
when I was 12 years old.
- Let’s see if there's any
other like, action ones.
- I met the AjA Project
when I was in middle school.
I was in 8th grade.
It's a group of youth and
some adults who are working
on improving the community.
They teach you how to take
pictures and how to tell
your story, and at the same
time giving voices to people
who don't have the opportunity
to tell their stories.
I got fascinated 'cause
I didn't speak English,
so I used photography to tell my story.
The way I capture images
changed throughout time.
I guess at first when I
didn't have the digital camera
it was like, you have to
go develop your images
and then come back, and then you're like
ooh I don't like that buy another roll
and then take it again.
Now you have the DSLR,
where you just take a picture
and then it automatically
goes to your computer.
Before that they had
this big computers to put
the memory card in the computer.
You have to use a wire and then
plug it, it was complicated.
Now it's much simpler.
Photography and technology,
they go hand in hand.
Not having technology is very different.
Back home we didn't have any cameras.
We couldn't just go to the
store and buy a camera,
even the disposable ones.
So we didn't have pictures of us younger.
Like my mom, she doesn't know
what she look like back then.
I don't know what I look
like when I was a baby.
We don't have any photos,
so I wanted to change that
for my kids.
The Famo who is mother
and then the Famo who's a photographer.
The one thing they have in
common it’s saving memories.
Things become history in like a second,
so that's why I love taking
pictures all the time.
When people think of refugee
they don't go out there
to ask a refugee person.
Every group has like, the little box
that people put them in.
Each person has to be able
to tell you who they are
and where they come from.
A computer gives you a way
to connect with the world.
I want the next generation
to be open minded,
to follow their dreams, not
to let anybody speak for them.
(light music)